[Music]
yeah good evening I'm Stuart brand from
long now
the speakers can talk about the
difference between price and value and I
think in terms of long now one of the
differences between price and value is
time pricing or volatile market is this
instantaneous erratic thing doesn't hold
still whereas value is something more
durable so if the speaker is talking
about rethinking markets in terms of
value she's thinking markets in terms of
more long now ish way please welcome the
lady in red
Mariana motsek Otto thank you
Thank You Stuart is this on
yes I was actually gonna wear white but
I was told not to so I put on this great
red dress and then I had to put on this
microphone which was impossible so I had
to lift up the dress but I did it to it
here I did in the back which is all good
anyway so that was a really interesting
video if I write on this piece of paper
I Oh
Stuart five pounds and it's backed by
government this is money and it's very
interesting the whole question of what
is money and do we have limits do we
actually need taxation to go to war
there's a huge debate about that right
now in the US and I'm not going to talk
about this I'm actually going to talk
about what we need to do to revive a
real discussion a serious discussion
about how to reform capitalism which has
gone wrong and I'm not the first person
who will tell you that it's gone wrong
but to really bring back a serious
debate where then the walk is as serious
as the talk in terms of also rethinking
value chains inside companies so we
don't just rely on for example
philanthropic giving or different ways
to patch up the system and it's a really
interesting time to be talking about
this because there's this desire if one
can call it that in both business and in
politics too refined purpose in the
economy so this was a famous letter that
Larry Fink the CEO of Blackrock wrote to
500 CEOs last year 2018 basically saying
we've screwed up we are you know we've
lost our way we're no longer investing
back in the workforce we've become to
short-term is just worried about our
quarterly returns we've got to change
and the same kind of discussions are
being had basically both on the right of
the political spectrum and the left so
in the UK where I'm coming from there
was at Miliband when he was the head of
the Labour Party he talked about the
need for more responsible type of
capitalism and actually was quite
specific and he used some words that I'm
gonna be using tonight he said we need a
more productive form of capitalism less
unproductive but also you know what kind
of productive what are we actually
producing are we reaching a more
sustainable and inclusive form of
capitalism or less so but this whole
debate
about productive versus unproductive
value wealth creation and really the
admission that economic growth has not
just a rate but a direction and that we
need to bring that issue of
directionality to the fore is the
opportunity that we have tonight and you
know hopefully over the next next decade
to actually reach for example these
amazing goals that countries around the
world have set themselves the 17
sustainable development goals these are
recent we have never had a period in
history where countries agreed on a set
of goals like that but again what does
it mean to actually transform business
practices transform how governments work
how they are instruments behave both the
money creation but also things like
procurement and grants how labor unions
interact with capital capital labor
relations all this is really important
because markets write the word the
market capitalism and the markets
markets are outcomes we often confuse
the word market with business markets
are outcomes of how business different
types of businesses small medium and
large
different types of public entities
different types of third sector entities
including trade unions and
philanthropies interact but also how
they're themselves governed within their
organizations and this is sort of the
call that I want to make tonight that we
really have to get serious about the
internal governance of the different
institutions which through their
interactions form the kind of capitalism
that we have and it's no good just to
talk about climate change or inequality
if we're not serious about these kinds
of changes that are absolutely required
in the governance structures and this
call for purpose which we keep hearing
about unfortunately not much is changing
and I think because we're not going deep
into the governance of these
organizations and I want to do so by
actually talking about value because I
fundamentally think that values actually
created collectively and looking at how
different organizations collectively
interact often problematically but also
how they're governed problematically I
think has to be the center of how we
think about reforming capitalism now be
doing that I want to depress you just a
bit basically just to remind you how bad
things are and how little things have
actually changed since one of the
biggest crises of all time the second
biggest financial crisis really the one
that began in 2007 2008 and so I'm going
to just very quickly depress you of it
but I promise I will get to hopeful
positive things towards the end and we
have a huge amount of time so for big
fat problems the first I'll call the
financial problem the finance problem
and this is really what I mean by this
is the problem within the financial
sector and I'm going to be a bit
superficial here cuz I'm going to go
through lots of both economic thinking
and also economic history but what I
mean by this is a kind of
financialization of finance in other
words finance is financing finance and
what you see here in this curve this is
for the UK economy but the US economy
looks quite similar the degree to which
the financial sector has outpaced in its
size the rest of the economy so this is
looking at financial intermediation
which is basically banks but also whole
shadow banking system in all forms of
different types of financial
institutions growing much faster than
the rest of the economy and basically
this is because so much of the financial
sector has ended up just financing
finance insurance and real estate which
conveniently the acronym is higher and
so you know this often makes people
think oh god this is terrible we need to
kind of define analyze and kind of fuel
industry right so this is also why in
some countries industrial policy has
come back and the idea that we need to
kind of fuel the makers so these are the
takers and unfortunately this brings me
to the second problem which is that
industry has become very financialized
itself and by that I mean that
increasingly in many large companies and
this is data here for 466 of the S&P 500
companies the profits being earned or
not actually being reinvested back into
production back into the workforce
human capital and skill research and
development but used for exactly the
kind of things that Larry Fink was in
theory theory warning about so things
like share buybacks and so this data
here shows you that between 2008 so a
to the financial crisis to 2017 these
466 big companies spent over four to
four trillion dollars in share buybacks
which was equivalent to 53 percent of
their profits along with three point one
trillion as dividends and this would be
fine as long as they were all so you
know again reinvesting back in but that
yellow bit there which is the
reinvestment back into production
including skills has been falling and
you see this by the way also at the
macroeconomic level you might know that
GDP gross domestic product which is how
we measure output of the economy can be
broken down in different ways one of it
is on the spending of all the different
components of the economy so government
spending gee business spending I
consumption spending and that exports
and the iPart business investment has
been falling and this is not a
coincidence right this is precisely
because there hasn't been that
reinvestment I'm just going to say one
thing is I often forget to say it and
apologies if I often do these little
parentheses but this is a huge problem
and this basically is you know much more
of a problem than the so called the
robots are taking our jobs
it's very interesting if you look back
at the history of economic thought and
I'll be going through quite a bit of
history in just a minute David Ricardo
one of the first economists ever in 1821
wrote a book called principles of
political economy and chapter 31 don't
ask me how I remember these details I
can't remember what he did this morning
but chapter 31 of this book that he
wrote in 1821 called on machinery he
warned that this rise and machines were
displacing labor he was very worried
about the effect that the rise of the
machines today's robots would be having
on employment and wages but what we
ended up having for basically 200 years
and it kind of stopped around the 1980s
and onwards was that as long as profits
were being reinvested back into the
economy he kind of did it matter
machines yes took jobs in one part of
the economy but as long as profits were
invested they reappeared in other places
and skills were also formed as an
endogenous function of that investment
process right skills don't only come
from workers sorry from government
training programs
they also come from if you're kind of
taken care of inside the company if
you're invested in and this is just
really important because there's so much
talk today about the future of work in
the robots what's going to happen
without actually putting these numbers
in this data at the center of the
picture as just as important to confront
and this is a corporate governance
problem so this was problem - sorry
little distraction there problem three
is that in a time where we would really
need serious ambitious policy as
ambitious as the kind of policies that
got us the welfare state or that got a
man to the moon and back again in one
generation we basically have states that
have been convinced by well
unfortunately by economists we
unfortunately have lots of influence
that at best they can just kind of
tinker on the sidelines you always have
to first identify the market failure and
then you're allowed to do something and
this kind of leads to this very patchy
view of what policy is for so in a
moment where we're calling for things
like a green transition and I'll get to
this in a second the fourth problem is
in fact climate change when we need to
in theory we're talking about it
approach the sustainable development
goals for real where we have a rise in
inequality at least relative inequality
in many countries and there's to talk
about reforming capitalism this idea
that you're just there patching up the
system and putting band-aids when it
goes wrong is simply not going to get us
what we need and it's not that these
market failures don't exist this is the
term that economists use market failures
and you always have to identify the
market failure before policy does
anything they do exist so let me just
give you some examples here when you
have positive externalities so goods
that create these really great spillover
is that it's hard to appropriate the
returns just for yourself you will have
under investment by the private sector
in that area so government comes in and
invests in things like basic research
the opposite when businesses are
producing too much of something that is
not good a negative externality then
government comes in and does something
like a carbon tax when you have
asymmetric information so cute little
companies don't get enough money because
the the banks don't actually know
anything about them because they don't
have enough history then you might need
government to come in and do SME lending
so again all these things you know
happen and and this framework isn't
completely useless but in a time where
there's at least talk about
rediscovering purpose in reforming
capitalism and rethinking the direction
not just the rate these tools are part
of the problem and forth as I just kind
of gave it away before the climate
problem this is kind of the problem if
we don't sort this everything else is
kind of irrelevant we've got twelve
years left the IPCC report if you
haven't read it read it
Greta young woman reminds us that our
house is literally on fire second time I
use the word fire interesting you can
use it both for climate change and the
financial sector it's probably not a
coincidence and you know and
unfortunately it's not just that there's
not enough spending on renewable energy
this also is data from the IPCC so
apparently we're only spending about 20%
of what we should be in terms of really
getting a renewable energy revolution
going but Green is not just about
renewable energy it's really about
transforming how our economies work so
getting some old manufacturing sectors
to reduce the material content and the
history of capitalism we've often
required real kind of bold demand side
policies not just that supply push and
we're not getting those on okay so
that's the depressing that for massive
problems which kind of is why we need to
rethink if we don't have those problems
who cares we could be talking about
something else
so what I did in my book the value of
everything was to kind of bring it down
to first principles and ask could it be
that also we've just kind of lost our
way and stopped really debating
something that actually in the course of
the last kind of 200 years of thinking
about the economy was really central
this question of you know what is value
what is value creation what is value
extraction and what happens when we
either by my mistake or on purpose end
up rewarding value extraction more than
value creation do we get something
called value destruction but you know I
just keep using that word value there
but what is value and notice by the way
that the subtitle is not makers versus
takers because that's really static that
would lead to the rest of my 40 minutes
here kind of making a list of big bad
finance hedge
credit default swaps bad and then kind
of saying that something else is good
that's not what I'm gonna do is making
and taking the reason I chose that kind
of verb is that we can change things we
can and I hope perhaps we can talk about
it also in the Q&A we can fundamentally
reform how finance is operating and how
certain business practices have kind of
gone astray and how government has just
become a bit too lame but what's really
interesting is that this kind of concept
of making and taking kind of often comes
back after every financial crisis so I
pulled out this quote here which is very
nice one by big bill Haywood the first
industrial trade unionist in the US
writing at the time of the great crash
in 1929 and it's really interesting
because you just replace the word gold
barons by financial sector and it kind
of rings what a lot of people and
communities around the world were saying
so the barbarous gold barons they didn't
find the gold they didn't mind the gold
they didn't mill the gold but by some
weird magic alchemy all the gold belongs
to them and so this is the kind of
making and taking and and you know this
is kind of the accusation but so what
does this mean what does it mean to
actually think about the economy in
terms of certain areas being kind of
productive certain being unproductive
and really thinking about how to make
sure we're steering activities inside
what I call in the book the production
boundary and unfortunately what happens
when we no longer talk about value and
just kind of assume you know Silicon
Valley is full of wealth creators we end
up allowing stories literally just
stories and narratives and discourses
about value and wealth creation to take
over and what I'm going to basically
argue is that when that happens we allow
value extraction to be disguised as
value creation and you know it's not
that the landlords and the 1700's and
I'll get to them in a minute weren't
extracting value but they didn't pretend
to be innovative didn't pretend to be
value creators they just say give me
your damn money and people gave them the
money Adam Smith called landlords fees
there was no masquerading and again I'm
not
gonna don't worry I'm sure there's many
tech people here in the room I'm not
gonna start making accusations of again
whether it's tech or finance or
government officials as value extractors
but this kind of masquerading exercise
is a problem and you know there's I was
really struck how one year just one year
after the crisis the head of Goldman
Sachs Lloyd blank Fein said with a
completely straight face it was not an
after-dinner speech or he's trying to
make people laugh yeah completely
serious look it up just google it and
the FT put this quote that Goldman Sachs
workers were the most productive in the
world you know I mean this is a period
where they had just been bailed out ten
billion dollars by the US government
because of what happened with the
financial crisis there was plenty of
evidence that it was in fact to a large
extent not only the activities of the
large investment banks that at least
partially led to the financial crisis
and yet this bold statement of we are
the most productive in the world and so
this whole concept of how do we measure
productivity do teachers say we are the
most productive in the world and if not
could it be that how we're actually
accounting for a value in the system
creates actually a self-fulfilling
prophecy that it allows some actors in
the economy to be very bold and arrogant
and and and to be able to claim even
just logically in terms of how we do the
counting that they are so productive but
then again I I mentioned story so this
idea that again wealth creators in
Silicon Valley or in the case of brexit
when brexit I'm still hoping it doesn't
happen but um happened you know this
idea that we have to at least protect
those really valuable sectors which
which were producing value for the UK
economy so financial services and I'll
mention also later the way that the word
value is used in sectors like the
pharmaceutical industry to justify very
high increases and prices so recently a
price of an antibiotic went up by 400
percent overnight and the idea that
value-based pricing could somehow be
used to justify that as quite
extraordinary and on the opposite
spectrum I've already mentioned teach
you don't hear teachers calling
themselves we are so productive but also
the state itself how we talk about the
state we don't talk about it really as
creating value at best we talk about it
as redistributing value or enabling or
de-risking the value creators so these
are really just words and narratives and
discourses which are kind of just I
don't say [ __ ] but just kind of
stories right economics is not nuclear
physics and we've allowed by not
actually talking about value these
stories to be out there and almost not
even questions so I'm gonna start
questioning it and to do so I will have
a drink not a Jenna tonic but water mmm
so I will go through again quickly and
there's always the risk that when you do
something too quickly its superficial
but it will be fun the history of
economic thought for the last 400 years
so what's interesting is that if you
look at the history of economic thought
there was a real correlation between
what was actually happening in the
economy and society really not the
economy and how value was talked about
so in the 1600s this is a period of the
ships
you know crossing the Seas and the 1651
Navigation Acts it was a period which we
call mercantilism where the idea was
really that value occurred through
exchange and so there's lots of
attention on exchange rates and terms of
trade and what kind of trade agreement
would be needed you know so this is
starting to make you think we've gone
back to mercantilism right and in many
ways Trump has brought us back 400 years
but whatever I won't go there so but
what then happened which was really
interesting in the 1700's and 1800's
that attention left the kind of just
pure exchange economy and went to
production and so on the physiocrats who
were writing the 1700s this was a period
in which you know is still basically
agricultural society it's not surprising
they really believed that value occurred
in agriculture and the farm labor itself
produced value and so they basically
produced the first spreadsheet ever and
fronts wocken a a french man did it and
you can see nothing there so I've made
it for you more visible
and they divided the economy into these
three classes farm labor where the
productive class the merchants or those
selling things were the home the
proprietors and then he called the
landlord's the sterile class right I
mean this is like real sexual
connotation in in the sense of the
reproduction of the system so when you
have money being siphoned out of the
system go back to my financial graphs
before being siphoned out that's
threatened the reproduction of the
system so they did this whole little
analysis here looking at okay this
amount of my of goods are produced by
the farmers then a certain amount of
funds are used just to move that stuff
around in terms of exchange and selling
the goods that were produced by the
farmers and then however there were the
landlords who were simply charging rent
on the land and we're basically just
moving things around and they were
basically seen as the huge problem let
me just go back unfortunate my there
yeah
and so their real focus there was on the
reproduction of the system but also in
terms of increasing the productivity of
the land itself so as that focus both on
how do you increase the productivity of
the farms but also real attention that
the funds were not been siphoned out
whether it's to fight the wars or simply
the landlord's being able to dress
themselves better and charging money for
basically doing very little in the 1800s
this is a period of the Industrial
Revolution I already mentioned before
1821 David Ricardo is a chapter on
machinery it's not surprising that in
that period they focused on industrial
labor and the classical economists you
know there was basically Adam Smith
David Ricardo and Karl Marx they all
really shared this attention to what I
would call the objective conditions of
production Adam Smith's book The Wealth
of Nations was very much focused on I
think I have a nice picture here on the
division of labor itself so he had this
wonderful a pin Factory example where he
looked at you know if one guy has to do
everything for a pen at most he's going
to make one pin a day whereas if you
divide that task into this 18 different
areas then you actually increase
productivity by a drastic degree so you
can actually make
100 sorry 4,600 pins a day if you
increase that division of labor which
increases productivity which increases
growth which increases the wealth of
nations and he was also very interested
as were recorder and Marx in this notion
of productive and unproductive and it
wasn't negative to be unproductive so
Smith also you know has this great quote
where he's like yeah well some of these
things that aren't productive or also
just kind of fun right and you know
going to hear musicians and I don't
think he liked the Opera very much
because if you look at this quote you
know he must have the night before
writing The Wealth of Nations going to a
really crappy opera cuz he's like in the
unproductive are musicians
opera singers and offer dancers you know
this whole list there's three three
categories of buffoons and all of you I
mean how many lawyers are in the room
doctors professors you know anyway
there's no tech here so and so the point
was actually in Smith what's interesting
he literally made a list he did what I
said I tried not to do in the book of
just makers versus takers what Marx did
was much more refined some ways he was
much less deterministic what he was
interested in was you know there there
is a capitalist system he believed it
was based on the exploitation of labor
so he's also very interested in what
happens when you increase mechanization
and machines displace labor and then the
source of of profits potentially
disappears and he was very interested as
was David Ricardo and this whole issue
again of reinvestment back into the
system and all three of them really
hated rent in fact how many of you have
heard the word free-market all of you
what is that it's free from just yell it
out free from the well yet because
you've heard me say that before I pin
you're not supposed to say things that
I've told you my kids or your kids to do
free from the state that's what people
think it's completely not true for Adam
Smith the free market was free from rent
they really believed that this was the
problem in the system and for them rent
was basically unearned income it was
just some of the actors in the economy
just moving stuff around and doing
nothing else and that was a problem
because that wouldn't increase in the
productivity and and growth and so this
real focus on the
objective conditions of production which
translated for them also introduced
tribution of the income so they looked
at the distribution of profits wages
rents and interest with the real focus
on reducing those rents was very
interesting and you know this attention
to the objective conditions included
things like class struggle so to
understand wages they looked at class
relationships now what happens with
neoclassical economics which is what we
have today which is what is taught all
over the world in economics departments
is that the attention moves away from
kind of a theory of value and attention
to production to actually focusing on
prices and using prices to reveal value
it moves away from an attention to the
objective conditions of production to a
focus on the subjective conditions so
again really sorry very superficial here
but you know it's it's basically all
based on individual decisions so the
assumption that consumers when we go buy
stuff we are maximizing our individual
utility just think I'm kind of happiness
workers are maximizing their decisions
of leisure versus work firms are
maximizing their profits and when you
look at the interactions between all
these individual preferences and
decision-making we get supply and demand
curves and we get our equilibrium prices
in those prices reveal value so it's a
complete reverse of the logic before it
was theories of value whether it's farm
labor industrial labor which then
determined basically theory of price and
all of a sudden we have a theory a price
which determines value so what's the
implication of this class struggle
disappears right so wages are again
determined by our preferences for
leisure versus work and could go into
that a bit more but I won't prices
reveal value so this is why my you know
brother often says to me if you're so
smart why don't you earn so much right
so this idea that somehow you know this
this link between income and value which
basically is why blank Fein was able to
say Goldman Sachs workers are the most
productive in the world because they
earn
of money and so because prices are
revealing value those that income is a
measure if you want up there
productivity and the really interesting
thing this is probably one of the most
profound things is that rent which you
know people talk about there's all sorts
of books now in inequality that talk
about rent rent is no longer unearned
income as you know Smith recorder and
Marx talked about literally people just
moving stuff around without doing much
but it's simply uncompetitive price and
some sort of monopoly power which in
theory once we get rid of the
imperfections can be competed away and
it's not that that's wrong or right but
it's just a big change in focus from
unearned income to lack of competition
and some sort of monopoly power that can
in theory be again removed if we get rid
of imperfections so who cares right I
mean was this just like really
interesting quick you know history of
economic thought no I'm gonna argue that
this really matters that when we
subjective I value and we put so much
attention just to in division divisional
decisions and kind of remove our focus
to the objective conditions of
production and by that I mean kind of
who's doing what what risks are being
taken for example if you look at
innovation right so we are at the hub of
of one of the world's centers of
innovation well who's actually doing
what across the whole innovation chain
just you know let's document it whether
it's in the pharmaceutical industry and
the tech area so this real attention
which you might have as a journalist or
as a common person but in economics we
don't really focus on that much anymore
we don't really focus on the division of
labor but you don't look at all the
different actors that might be required
in order to produce value and also
looking at how those actions the actual
risks taken in the actual production
along for example whole value chain is
or is not related to the income being
earned is there kind of a mismatch
rewards being kind of in excess of
what's actually being done and this this
again transformation of the focus on
objective - all of a sudden subjective
and the arrows going from price to value
value to price is precisely what enables
Liang Fein to say this with a complete
straight face and not as I said as an
after-dinner joke so why this matters is
because it affects so many things it
affects how we determine GDP and by the
way GDP was not meant to be by the guys
who and it was mainly guys who invented
it was not meant to be such a important
number that everyone's obsessing about
whether it's going up by 0.01 or down by
2 or whatever cruising it's worn don't
use it for that but we do but still how
we actually calculate it is very much
driven by prices I'm going to talk a bit
about that how we look at governance of
organizations and I would argue the lack
of debate about corporate governance
because not much is changing and again
think warrant but you know people have
been warning about the problem of
short-termism for a long time this is
not unrelated to how we measure value
how we price medicines I already
mentioned you know when prices go up by
400 percent overnight and it's somehow
justified based on value-based pricing
this is related to this problem the lack
of real I don't know what to say
transformation or serious debate about
what to do with the problems of rents in
platform capitalism I think are also
related to this confusion of price with
value and the role of the state you know
one a key issue which is you know if we
need serious policy in order to drive
the system in new ways and actually
really approach that directionality this
problem of a Mis measuring value and not
even knowing how to talk about value
creation within the state is a problem
so let me just kind of take these I'm
going to go through these again
relatively quickly but they're all
important so why not
so GDP I mean this is quite well known
it's quite fun to teach a macroeconomics
class even though I am personally more
of a micro economist I do economics um
innovation but I used to love one of the
first times I did this just to earn some
extra money doing my PhD giving examples
to the students of all the crazy things
like if you marry your cleaner GDP goes
down
if you pollute GDP goes up I'll let you
guys figure it out you can test them in
the Q&A if they actually figured I'll
put in the test but so you know so
feminist economists have been arguing
for a long time that we are Mis
measuring a fundamental attribute and a
system in our system we just care the
care we give to people at home to our
children to the elderly and just because
it doesn't have a price we don't put
into GDP that's a problem
environmentalists have been saying again
it's crazy that when we pollute GDP
doesn't go down it actually goes up
simply cuz we have to pay for someone to
clean it up that's kind of well-known so
I don't have to come here and tell you
that what's less known is coming you
know bringing this back to finance the
whole financial sector basically or most
of the financial sector was not even
included in GDP up until about 1970 and
this is because even though they didn't
realize they were doing that they were
the people doing the national accounts
were basically accepting the classical
idea of rent as unearned income so the
idea that was that most of finance for
example net interest payments which was
data that we had wasn't being included
in GDP because the idea was that it's
just moving stuff around it's not
actually doing much so what did go into
GDP in terms of the financial sector
were the fees for example that you would
be charged by the mortgage provider
because I was very clear there's a price
for that service you know mortgage
provision that goes into GDP because
there's a service and a price but net
interest payments what is that and all
of a sudden they started looking at
those numbers those very numbers I
showed you before and like oh my god and
they call this the banking problem and
by they I mean the people inside the UN
there is a group called the system or
inside a organ is a part of the UN call
the systems of national accounts they're
like we can't not include this massive
thing that's actually growing obviously
there's activity there and instead of
kind of just pausing a minute and doing
one of you know kanae is the physiocrats
kind of spreadsheets and trying to
understand what's productive what's
unproductive could it be that actually
this big blob is growing not because
it's actually contributing to society
but at least part of it potentially you
know is problematic because it's not
actually doing much more than moving
stuff around they just gave it a name so
they called the commercial banks net
interest payments
financial intermediation and the net
interest payments of the investment
banks risk taking an overnight bang it
goes into GDP now it's not as I said
before the the point is not to not put
it in because somehow it's just value
extraction that would be idiotic but
without any attention on what is the
form of finance that was growing what is
actually happening in the sector is it
productive is that unproductive are
there ways to actually reform it there
is very little discussion at the time
this attention just to we have to you
know if something has a price if it's
earning income it must be valuable just
kind of led to this kind of superficial
idea let's just give it a name and this
you know was very interesting actually
because as soon as Finance started to go
into GDP and was also seen as a
productive part of the economy that was
not unrelated to also the ability of the
sector to lobby for certain things like
deregulation but also that arrogance of
of seeing itself as very productive is
not unrelated to how we measure things
sociologist by the way call this
performativity how we measure the
performance of something then affects
how that something behaves which then
feeds back into how we measure the
governance of organizations just coming
back to this warning that think and
others have given actually for decades
again as I mentioned about the risks of
short-termism and the risks around
really believing that maximization of
shareholder value is the only way to
govern an organization so little has
changed and I think this is
fundamentally related to the fact we
haven't kind of debunked the underlying
assumptions behind the value theory of
maximization of shareholder value it's
not going to change if we just say it
leads the short-termism right that's
just the effect it has to change because
we have to say it's wrong it's the wrong
theory of value and I personally think
it's the wrong theory of value this is
all by the way subjective right we're
not again talking about physics this is
economics as a social science there's
different ideas so this is you know take
everything I'm saying in some ways with
a grain of salt but I believe that's
true
and the reason is is that if you look at
the text books of maximization of
shareholder value there's this
underlying us
sumption that shareholders are really
the biggest value creators but
specifically the biggest risk takers so
Michael Jensen writing in the 80s who
kind of was one of the first authors of
this approach called shareholders the
residual claimant so the idea is that
everyone else has a guaranteed rate of
return so banks have their guaranteed
interest rate workers will have their
guaranteed salary and at the end if
there's something left over it goes to
the shareholders so poor babies they get
nothing right and so they risk so much
so they deserve to get these big booties
at the end for example if some big
bubbles like the dot-com bubble the
clean tech bubble today and what's
interesting is that it company know that
completely dismisses the fact that
that's not true you know I I was here
when was I hear Stuart on 2013 no okay
yeah
presenting my book the entrepreneurial
state where basically I talked for
whatever amount of minutes for allowing
me to talk tonight 50 minutes on this
massive risk-taking roll actually of the
state everything in your phone that
makes it smart and not stupid unless
some of you have stupid phones was
funded by the public sector through
massive risk-taking internet GPS Siri
touchscreen display if you look today at
green technology much of the high-end
certain high risk capital intensive
investments have been taken on at least
initially by different types of public
institutions which then have crowded in
private institutions which is not to say
the private sector doesn't take risks of
course it does but we know that but this
idea that somehow only shareholders are
the biggest risk takers and have no
guaranteed rate of return ignores the
fact that for every Internet which was a
success there are six or seven failures
for every Tesla which received five
hundred million from the do-e there's
six or seven Solyndra that receive the
same amount of money so you know what's
required is an objective not a
subjective understanding of what's
actually happening in an area and only
by giving that attention to production
but widely understood I'm not talking
about production in a deterministic way
can this idea of maximization of
shareholder value be
debunked and potentially reformed prices
of medicines are quite interesting
because it's probably the most symbolic
or how do you say perfect example of
this confusion with price and value when
as I mentioned the price of the
antibiotic oh Goldman Sachs is great is
it always has these fantastic quotes
right curing people is not a good
business model because then actually
they wouldn't my stuff so you know
value-based pricing is literally the
idea that you know prices of drugs or
what the market will bear so you allow
prices to reveal how much people
actually want to drug and I mean I'm not
gonna go into the details of it but it
has no again objective attention to what
is actually happening in terms of that
division of innovative labor that both
Smith Ricardo Marx paid attention to and
it's quite mad or crazy that we allow a
system where the taxpayer is putting in
every year in this country over 30
billion a year for the research
underlying many of these drugs alongside
private pharma it's always alongside
it's not state versus business and yet
somehow the prices are not reflecting
that division of innovative labor so
National Institutes of Health Research
are responsible for something like 75%
of new molecular entities with priority
rating and again the prices are not
reflecting them and now who owns our
data is also an interesting question in
terms of the issues around platform
capitalism which is you know initially
think quite big here in San Francisco
and what again is interesting is that by
focusing on you know the stories of
wealth creation and so you know wealth
is created there and then we just have
to tax it we have to worry about privacy
in terms of you know the tech companies
today or either being taxed or being
told that there's all sorts of problems
in terms of privacy but they're not
being really challenged in terms of why
do you even have the data in the first
place so again the division of
innovative labor the collective creation
of value underlying much of the digital
economy if you look at it this idea that
sort of wealth creation is there and
then you
have to tax that wealth would be
dismantled in Barcelona in Spain what
they're looking at is how can you change
the relationships so precisely because
the technology which is used to retrieve
the day it has been publicly financed
again I've already mentioned internet
GPS but especially the data is of the
citizens every time you click on
something you are basically producing
data the idea that actually we could
fundamentally change relationships
instead of just taxing wealth is
interesting and so the chief digital
officer who I think Tim knows as well
Francesca but he and the team in
Barcelona are thinking about how could
we allow actually a public repository of
the data to be governed in new ways
where the data when it's generated goes
into the city to improve its public
transport again kind of fundamentally
changing how we think about value
creation in terms of institutions
organizations and the collective
creation of value versus just kind of
accepting values there and we're just
going to tack sense role of government
as I mentioned what's interesting is
that we literally in how we account in
GDP it's impossible to show the
productivity of government in that way
that Lloyd Blank Fein talked about
because especially with areas that
government produces that are free like
public education we don't know how to
value the quality of the public
education so we only put in the salaries
of the teachers not the value of a well
structured education system same thing
with the hospitals the costs of the of
the doctors and the nurses not the value
that they're producing but also it's
interesting is that the way in which
public servants around the world are
trained through new public management of
public choice Theory itself is kind of
derived from this notion that I
mentioned before that you know at best
what bureaucrats are doing or just
fixing markets or redistributing value
through taxation but are not actually
value creators themselves and this is
you know again just kind of a story that
has been accepted but if you actually
look as I mentioned a sector by sector
but also the big changes that have
occurred including right now worldwide
kind of attempts at least to battle
change there's lots of different types
of actors that are making investments
that are reimagining different spaces in
terms of clean cities and using the word
value creation only to describe what's
happening in business and not even using
it to describe the role of the
bureaucrat ends up creating the
self-fulfilling prophecy that we end up
actually getting quite inertial in
bureaucratic institutions because we
don't even have a way to talk about the
role of the state as potentially also
value creating anyway what to do so
first of all I've kind of repeated this
idea that you know markets are outcomes
of how public private third sector and
other organizations come together and
this really has to be translated into
this idea this real idea not just within
governance structures of organizations
but how they operate in the economy of
value as being created collectively and
that we we simply don't have that in
economics we have production functions
where you have you know capital and
labour and they meet and then output
comes about but we don't really have
this attention to how do we look at all
the different actors in an economy and
how they can together create value and
literally use the word wealth creator
and value creator for these different
entities which would mean if we did have
that that we would pay just as much
attention to the organizational
capabilities and capacities and
investments that are being made in all
these different types of organizations
that same call for purpose that's
required in terms of thinking about long
term ism and the reinvestment of funds
in terms of internal resources is really
also important in different types of
organizations including public sector
ones and markets themselves instead of
confusing markets with business we have
to fundamentally understand that markets
have over the course of the last 200
years and can be actively shaped and
co-created so this idea that at best we
are fixing markets really needs to be
replaced by an idea of co-creation and
Co shaping of markets and get rid of
these ideas that we're going to be
leveling the playing field in order to
get a green transition we really have to
tilt it but what does it mean to tilt
the playing field you know it doesn't
mean actually picking particular actors
in the economy to support of course not
but it does
mean to really bring that directionality
to the fore of the discussion and to
kind of transform how we understand
market mechanisms and fundamentally in
terms of coming back to this issue of
the production boundary there you know
by thinking of Co shaping and
co-creation of markets and not that
there's some market actors there and
then we just intervene in the system
it means you know actively steering
certain activities back into the
production boundary whether that's oh
sorry I'm looking at the computer
instead of the slides here um so so that
means reforming finance you know finance
financing finance does not have to be
the way to organize a financial sector
Minsky talked about that quite a bit so
it it Keynes but we've allowed that I
mean it's quite mad that we don't have a
financial transaction tax it's not
rocket science to realize that that
would help us get more long-term ism in
the economy and of course it would have
to be a global project but that's just a
policy but the reason to have that
policy really would come about from an
understanding that steering activities
into the production boundary but that
would require a discussion of value and
instead of just measuring the financial
sector by how much it's earning by
really rethinking how can we make it
more productive similarly d financial
izing the real economy in the 1918 till
the 1980s actually with the laws at the
time the security Exchange Commission
would have actually made it illegal to
how the level of share buybacks that we
have today so these are both due to
deregulation but also a lack of real
understanding of how to shape markets to
actually produce the kind of society
that we need we've allowed if you want
the economy to become so financialized
I'll just give you one example of just
how different things are you know Bell
Labs which I'm sure many people in the
room know was one of the most innovative
private sector laboratories inside AT&T
actually came about at a time where
government was much more confident about
these issues so 18t was forced to
reinvest its profits back into the
economy back into innovation back into
big innovation beyond telecoms
yep beyond the telecommunication sector
in order to retain its monopoly status
and so you know so that kind of
conditionality is is is very interesting
and creating a much more symbiotic a
mutualistic public/private partnership
would require talking about issues like
this
the prices of drugs the fact that they
don't you know reflect collective
efforts that's not a hard one we've just
written a whole report on that if you're
interested called the people's
prescription and what to do about it I
want to finish with with just an example
of what it would look like to really
form partnerships between what I've been
calling collective value creators and
the economy to actually really redefine
purpose both within organizations but
also in terms of how they're relating to
achieve goals and and also really
question you know in many cases this is
just about new types of relationships
and policies or do we fundamentally also
need new types of institutions and
social innovations around those
institutions personally I just actually
formed a whole department around this
kind of thinking with this notion of
public purpose at the center so the
Institute for innovation public purpose
that have set up at UCL so just welcome
you to interact with us around this
because what I'm about to go through
with us and as as an example we're
working on globally especially with
cities and different regions that are
really kind of bringing the notion of
purpose to the fore I'm and one of the
things we've been trying to do is really
to change the vocabulary the vocabulary
that has we've sort of accepted and
almost you know we I work with
policymakers all around the world and
this notion that you know one actor is
de-risking another actor fundamentally
is reproducing this value narrative and
discourse that value is created in one
part and at best you're enabling and
facilitating de-risking that value
creator so if we really want to get
purpose within different organizations
and also use that to tackle big societal
challenges together these kinds of kind
of laying words of one actor fixing
another one and leveling the playing
field and being the Len
of last resort you know lots of these
terms themselves have to be unpicked and
reveal the problematic value
propositions on top of which they lie so
this this notion of missions and and
it's interesting to reflect on this of
course because it's the 50th anniversary
of the Apollo mission this notion of
missions I think are really interesting
way to kind of unpick purpose in both
the business sector and the public
sector so just reflect a minute you know
to get to the moon and back again which
I mentioned before required real kind of
imagination a goal to be set but
fundamentally dynamic and in
economy-wide interactions between
different actors to fuel investment in
innovation for a common purpose so there
was the challenge the broad challenge
was at the time the space race and
Sputnik the moon shot was very specific
but it required many different sectors
to innovate not just Aeronautics there
was nutrition and materials there was
about 12 different sectors and then what
government did was really transform its
instruments like procurement and prize
schemes and grants to fuel that
bottom-up experimentation so over 300
projects in order to get to the moon of
which many failed so again that kind of
risk-taking really shared across many
different actors but also you know
bottom-up experimentation also in
business in order to reach a common goal
and so what we've been working on is
what would it look like actually to
really unpick this word purpose in a
moment where we not only have a fiftieth
anniversary of the moonshot but we
simply are not even getting any closer
to these SDG so if you take the 17
sustainable development goals transform
them into concrete missions which then
really require public and private and
third sector actors to interact in
productive ways but also in conditional
way so if you look at the massive
amounts of subsidies and guarantees and
investments that governments give
businesses worldwide these would become
also conditional on businesses
transforming themselves and investing in
areas with some sort of common purpose
of course also with commercial benefit I
mean this is not about nonprofits
and what's interesting is also that by
doing that it also changes how we think
about inclusive growth inclusive growth
is not all is no longer this idea of
redistribution you know there's no
there's I don't think it's a coincidence
that the that the Community Action in
Silicon Valley has liked you bi it
completely reproduces the usual
narrative right wealth is created here
oh and here's a handout to the citizens
thinking about this co-creation and
collective value creation idea which
fundamentally also requires again an
objective understanding of who's doing
what across a whole different innovation
space you know really kind of begs the
question well how do we make sure that
we're not just socializing risks but
also socializing rewards and I already
mentioned one way to do that is
conditions on reinvestment which would
also tackle the two problems that I
talked about at the beginning those two
twin phases of financialization but also
you know there's other ways to also have
conditionality one of the things which
you might know is currently a big
problem is the way that intellectual
property rights and patents which
there's nothing wrong with patents but
how we've allowed them to evolve in ways
that are very problematic so patents are
too upstream in the innovation chains or
actually patenting the tools for
research they're too wide we're allowing
them to be too too much used just for
strategic reasons they're too strong so
hard to license we could actually make
strong conditions attached to those
kinds of areas which can be redesigned
and reshaped in this market co-creation
market shaping kind of mentality but as
a condition also to have a 20-year
monopoly I mentioned this you know
example with Tesla and Solyndra what's
interesting is that what Obama said to
Tesla was if you don't pay back the loan
we get three million shares in your
company and why you would want three
million shares in a crappy company that
doesn't pay back its loan is kind of
beyond me he had all the goldman sachs
guys working for him in the white house
they could have at least comes through
then and had he taken had he taken three
million shares when the loan was
actually paid back the price per share
went from nine to ninety and that would
have more than covered the Solyndra loss
in the next round of investment
that's not just like a strategic point
that requires that kind of level of
confidence of you in the economy being
an active co-creator and market shaper
and not just a regulator and was also
interesting with Obama when he did the
Affordable Care Act and he was accused
of meddling in people's health care at
best he gave a Social Democratic answer
I know in America you don't use the word
Social Democratic but that's what he did
he said well this is the right thing to
do there's 60 million people uninsured
what he should have said was meddling
what are you talking about you know
again 75 percent of drugs are actually
funded by the state of course we have
the right to make sure they actually get
to the citizens and but that requires
again a different discourse narrative
vocabulary of you as a public entity
also creating a space not just
intervening not just regulating and this
is what I you know the reason I put that
quote by Plato before storytellers rule
the world it kind of is you know it's
really true the stories we are telling
first of all they're just stories the
economy is Astoria I loved how you
finish the sorry the the the guy who did
the video right he said this is just
something we've made up and you know
partly that's true / that's not true
with money but the point is we can
fundamentally change the system and it
will be very hard to change if we don't
debunk the ideas of where value creation
comes from and in the end I think this
is a very hopeful story because we do as
I said have a real opportunity this is a
moment where there's lots of discussions
not only about purpose but about
directionality you look around the world
there's talk about inclusive growth
sustainable growth innovation led growth
many economies like the UK economy
continued to be driven by consumption
led growth so the ratio of private debt
to disposable income is back to what it
was just before the crisis and that was
the cause of the crisis and so there's
you know this desire as I said at the
beginning for a change and if we don't
bring back the debate about value and
this isn't about which about you theory
is right or wrong but the debate and
contest the idea that some actors are
value creators and some are just Reed
distributors or facilitators or enablers
it's going to be impossible to change
the system so that's my call for action
and I'm done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of a long now question that was
fantastic thank you and I so raised it
at the beginning you said that value
becomes comes partly out of taking a
collective perspective on things and I
wonder if there's also kind of a long
now perspective on things you've had
some discussions with Brian Eno who was
one of the founding directors of this
organization and just the fact that the
art proneural government sort of takes
on things that these kind of long-term
risky dives into science into innovation
that companies would not usually do
because they can't it's just too long
trimmer for them too especially as they
start up to take on and is there along
our angle to the rethinking of value
that you want to make happen so first of
all I don't think so this isn't about
the state as a thing in itself like
there's the DNA of a stay to somehow
long term many states many state
institutions public organizations are
actually very short-term right because
of the electoral cycle for example or
because of the self-fulfilling prophecy
that's what the state is for is to get
past those election cycles right and so
there really is a self-fulfilling
prophecy that unless we you know
explicitly talk about value creation
amongst different actors and I would
include there I mean I mentioned trade
unions do trade unions create value oh
my god we wouldn't have the weekend
without trade unions we wouldn't have
the eight-hour work day without trade
unions and yet we don't use the word
value creation for what labor unions
have given to us so you know I'm from
Italy so you know the state you know
when when my African friends say Oh
Mariana you're talking about these
things we just have so much corruption
we can't I was like it's corruption we
taught you
you know I taught me don't even try it
we did that better than you so there's
so many problems with you know the
public sector as there are with the
private sector but whereas the private
sector has had a real internal
you know well first of all they go to do
MBAs you know where you do strategic
management decision sciences
organizational behavior it's all about
thinking out of the box that same level
of ambition is often not happen in the
public sector but that is not unrelated
to how we think about value that's sort
of the point here right now in real
estate it just kind of talked about what
the state does but we shouldn't forget
the state also does a lot of bad things
when it's long term it's not just the
this isn't a normative point the point
is when you do accept that your value
creator you also have to ask what am i
creating so fracking was a basically
government financed we only worried
about it after the fact
and so when you admit this valuation
process it's not just a rosy picture
it also should create more tension more
debate more contestation more democratic
potential in terms of citizens also
being aware and questioning what's being
created and what was interesting is that
because we don't admit that the state is
or at least in in in in common places we
don't kind of talk about the status
value creator that was not unlinked to
the fact that we didn't actually talk
about fracking ex-ante we just talked
about it ex post and I think most people
wouldn't even today know that fracking
was basically government financed and so
what what is required is a real when I
say co-creation and this example of the
missions the first question is well who
decides what the mission is is it a
top-down kind of Kennedy kind of thing
or do we really rethink in this
opportunity to rethink capitalism the
new ways in which we can get real civic
engagement even in framing missions in
the first place and in Germany where
they've recently had their entity event
a policy which is in no way perfect but
what was interesting was that it would
never have happened without the green
movement bringing sustainability to the
fore and so one of the questions we
should ask is do we even have the
capacity within governments to welcome
the engagement with movements in framing
kind of this purpose and that is
important I think for government
agencies but you need the capability to
do that to do that we need empathy 101
kind of classes speaking of green I
gather you've had some interaction with
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes oh I see and
green new deal what's your perspective
on her
yeah so I've been talking to her for
about a year and a half mm-hmm so before
she was elected um and I think she is I
mean as a person we can talk about her
but she's extremely bright she listens
she's interacted with lots of different
people I think also others in this room
that I know she's talked to um and I
think what's really interesting with the
green new deal is that it's as I
mentioned it's not just about renewable
energy right it really is about greening
an economy I do think there's a bit of
danger though putting everything in the
pot in the soup so I think it's very
smart to not you know to talk about the
way that we need a green-ink of every
sector I already mentioned I think
before I think I mentioned I can't
remember it you know like in Germany the
steel sector has reduced its material
content through repurpose reuse and
recycle there's actually a condition for
the kind of loans it was getting from
its public bank so really understanding
you know a green transformation of our
entire economy but that's separate from
I think Medicare for all
I mean that's a really ambitious
redistribution of policy and it's very
important to put it in a kind of a New
Deal perspective but putting everything
under the green New Deal potentially
makes it also messy and gives an excuse
for kind of not getting it done because
it just becomes you know such a big kind
of challenge so all these different
policies are definitely interrelated
mostly cuz if you have properly
distributional policies you're also
potentially doing especially if they're
designed well what about dissent talks
about which is he says we can't actually
thrive and flourish as a society unless
everyone has kind of basic opportunities
and capabilities and you know ubi is
sometimes trying to frame things like
that but the problem with ubi is again
as I mentioned it's it doesn't debunk
the narrative of men of the handout I'm
much more interested in a universal
basic kind of dividend or citizens share
because it just gives that agency to
citizens as having created value and
getting you know a share of what they've
created versus a handout from the wealth
creators and some other part of the
economy
so I think there were new deals very
ambitious one version of the
carbon tax has been proposed as a sort
of a universal basic share the idea that
that particular tax would basically be
divided by the number of people in the
nation that has that tax and everybody
gets that piece is that the kind of
thing that might make sense and in terms
you're talking about um in terms of a
carbon tax carbon tax I mean a carbon
tax is different from I mean I know I'm
thinking more I mean so this is
interesting because how you design a
policy really matters so you know I mean
the universal basic income is first of
all one of the reasons I think it's
problematic is that we already have
something called universal basic
services or in countries with proper
welfare states we do so sorry the u.s.
is a bit barbaric on that sense but you
know the degree to which you bi or or I
don't I've never heard the carbon tax
being framed in terms of universal
actually come up a number of times but
that would be the most equitable thing
to do with a carbon tax is that
basically everybody gets a stake okay
shockingly equal way right okay I mean
what's interesting is also it's
happening in France now with with the
Yellow Jackets and I think one you know
just coming bringing back the you know
notion of the green New Deal and what it
means also for the taxation system and
who actually benefits more or less or if
it's gonna be you know something that's
very interesting that's happening with
the trade union movement is this idea of
the just transition then when you
actually transition from a fossil based
economy to a greener one there's going
to be lots of people left behind you
know so the taxation that they
introduced in France you know there was
a real resistance to it and this is what
I mean by you know if we don't
fundamentally redesign the system itself
in the institutions and the kind of
stakeholder engagement is going to be
really hard to change things so the fact
that trade unions haven't been really at
the table defining the green transition
but are just worried about it post facto
and trying to defend workers who are
going to be potentially left behind is
part of the problem itself and so having
a real
stakeholder governance not only of
organizations because there is that
whole debate and the varieties of
capitalism stakeholder versus
shareholder maximization but literally
how we engage as a society to even
define the kind of ambitions that we
have ahead bringing labour back to the
table ex ante and having a real
discussion it's not just trade unions
but you know different voices to the
table to define these big shifts that's
I think one of the biggest challenges we
have their you know populism is you know
there's all sorts of different causes
behind it but people really feel that
they have been left behind you know
globalization and technology it's not
affecting many people's lives and so how
we can bring you know make politics
matter show that policies matter
designing proper policies matter to
people's daily lives also requires them
to be at the table when we're talking
about themselves what other politicians
actually people in politics besides
young new congresswoman from the Bronx
who's paying attention to you or any of
the presidential candidates aware of
what you're putting out like with Warren
or Warren
she invited me back in when was it 2016
to give evidence to the Senate around
this issue pharmaceutical pricing and
we've been in contact over the last
month she has a bill out on that I met
with her team actually just two weeks
ago hmm
in the you in Europe I mentioned this
document on missions it's actually now
become law so as a report I had the
honor to write for the competition
Kesari for the innovation commissioner
kind of smoosh a Portuguese Commissioner
for the European Commission so they have
a hundred billion euros in the horizon
program to fund innovation it sounds
like a lot but it's not if you divide by
European GDP and the missions concept
was voted on so it's now legal
instrument through which part of the
horizon program will be managed so the
idea is that instead of just kind of
blabbing about challenges it becomes
something very concrete through which
you use the innovation budget to kind of
focus on 10 or 15 missions that require
though many different sectors across
Europe and then those bottom-up
experimentation
that's now law in the UK what we did was
we used it also to rethink the
industrial strategy as I mentioned
industrial strategy across the world has
come back after being a blasphemy for
quite a few decades but the risk is it
just becomes a list of sectors so in the
UK in recent years there is a list of
five sectors automotive aerospace
financial services creative industries
and life sciences and our point was no
don't do that
that's when you get captured very
quickly by having a mission oriented
industrial strategy you set problems and
challenges that society faces and use
all your different sectors to tackle
those together and similarly in Scotland
which might aid that mission sorry how
would you state that mission instead of
those sectors how should the mission be
well so what the government then did was
it chose and we were actively kind of
informing them for broadly to find
challenges and they were clean growth
future of mobility healthy aging and the
opportunities around AI and big data
that was a strange one because that's
more of a general purpose technology not
so much a challenge so once they've set
those four challenges and that was done
you know basically through the
government that's why we have elected
democracies the idea was and that they
engaged very actively with different
stakeholders to make each one of those
broadly defined challenges into a set of
missions that again would require all
these sectors not a list of just four or
five or an AI by the way I think as a
cross-cutting one across any mission
whether it's health or future mobility
but just lastly in Scotland when I talk
about new institutions this idea that
you know we need more financier isn't
enough finance for whether it's SMEs or
the SDGs that's false there's plenty of
finance it's often just impatient
finance even venture capital is very
impatient you know three to five years
they want to exit through an IPO or a
buyout that created huge problems for
sectors like biotech so what we often
need is long-term committed strategic
capital and this is why some countries
have set up public banks so I'm an
advisor for Nicola Sturgeon advisor to
set up a public bank but said be careful
don't turn this into a handout machine
or that whichever business or sector
shouts the loudest make it a bank that
actually provides that patient long-term
finance to those organisations that are
willing to engage with you and you
it's a title missions patient finance
alone is a revolution there the way it
is a question from Brian Schulman among
the economists what extent is there a
consensus that the house is on fire in
terms of how Greta uses it so we kind of
- basically it's in trouble I mean the
problem is that there's this if the
question is amongst economists mm-hmm
there's a lot of kind of introspection
about economic theory where it's gone
wrong and there's a movement really
about rethinking economics and there's a
bit of a danger there because economists
love to show how mathematical and
scientific they are compared to you know
the sociologists and the steel right and
and and so unfortunately part of the
rethink anomic movement has kind of
bought into that and is trying to make
economics more user-friendly you know
the idea is there's too much math we
need to make it much more about kind of
real life and the problem is that it's
not too much in math it's the wrong math
it's math from Newtonian physics and
it's all about you know equilibria and
unique equilibria and averages matter
and the representative agent there was
all sorts of other mathematical tools
that could have been used for example
from biology in fact lots of the
agent-based modeling today but that's
kind of ghettoized in economics it's not
out there at the center uses more kind
of metaphors and and mathematics from
biology but also my thesis actually was
using replicator dynamics oh yeah you
know distance from mean dynamics in
economics we assume averages so if you
you know in biology you couldn't explain
change if everyone looked the same right
distance from me and you show your
growth by how different you are from me
how different your fitness is and yet
this focus on averages and
Representatives actors and economics is
fundamentally different from how you
know growth and change just looked at in
other sciences and so I think what's
really important and this is what I
guess I was trying to do also in the
book is to kind of to debunk the
assumptions underlying the models versus
to say you know get rid of the math but
in terms of the house being on fire with
climate change unfortunately
my point about just seeing it as
patching up different types of market
failures it's not that we don't need the
carbon tax of course we need carbon
taxes but you know not really seeing the
green transition and the Green
Revolution that's required as an active
market co-creation and market shaping
process across that whole system is a
lost opportunity we should remember that
big revolutions in the previous waves of
technology for example mass production
would never have had the effect that
they did across the whole economy
without also really bold demand side
policies so suburbanization was
fundamental to the power of mass
production to really affect production
distribution consumption and
productivity and what we need today is
the equivalent of these kind of demand
side policies like suburbanization but
in a green direction and we're not
really getting except in some isolated
cases so here's another in a sense
national policy question from Kevin
Kelly can we learn anything about
reforming capitalism from China right so
you know my previous book was called
entrepreneurial state and when I think
of China I think of the adaptive State
try not really interestingly I think is
learning from the US in a moment that
the u.s. is unlearning from itself
it's it's it struck me that the first
thing Trump did when he came into office
was actually attack particular public
organizations arpa-e and PBS and what
China's been doing you know and I think
there's a question or whether it's gonna
be successful or not it's forming
actually quite active investor kind of
innovative public organizations but
they're huge they're huge it's not a
decentralized network of public
organizations across the whole
innovation chain as we had in the US so
the Chinese Development Bank is a
massive financial institution which has
provided loans up to nine billion for
many of its companies including wha why
why why wouldn't exist without the
Chinese Development Bank by the way
Hawaii which is on the news a lot is a
cooperative can you believe that and
they it was quite fun Oba Scott sorry
and Dalian I met I we they had a tea
ceremony in Dalian
because the World Economic Forum has a
youth component that meets and Dalian
and and Huawei executives asked me and
three other economists this was back in
I think 2013 to meet with them to say
what should we do about the US it was
very strange I mean thinking about
what's happening now and really what do
you mean like well yeah it's really hard
in the u.s. it's we're not really
penetrating the market and my advice was
tell them you're cooperative I mean just
in terms of kind of getting you know
what I think is interesting in China is
there's a lot of variety
there's not one model there's lots of
different types of organizations hence
the hallway example it's a cooperative
they're state-owned companies there's
companies that are actually going more
towards slowly I think a more
market-driven anglo-saxon model of us
but there's variety there there's also
much more meritocracy in terms of who
works in government than we have in many
countries in the UK there's very little
matter autocracy in terms of who
actually rises up in government there's
lots of experiments actually at the
community level but it is also you know
it's it's you know it has problems of
democracy so it's not it's not one you
know it's not a cut-and-paste model from
you know communist versus capitalist but
how it evolves the degree to which there
is engagement you know for example
they're spending 1.7 trillion on
greening their economy coming back to
the green missions and this is out of
urgency mm-hmm and it's really
interesting how also in the u.s. big
things happen when there is urgency you
know when there's war and if you've seen
also the documentary on the Roosevelts
it's fantastic when there was urgency
big things happen in the US and so the
degree to which this urgency creates
because of pollution is creating both
are very positive change so 1.7 trillion
on greening the economy including energy
friendly technologies not just renewable
energy but also kind of that rush to
create and invest and not focus on
really rebalancing the whole economy for
example around consumption and services
is is causing the economy to be
unbalanced three questions relating to
sort of organizations and governors
katherine fulton area Matt Stairs
can you give me an example of an
organization
with the kind of governance structure
you would like to see Amelia Evans asks
how specifically would you reform
corporate governance so it creates value
and William Petrie asks lean back lean
manufacturing which is a valid very
value focused movement was rejected by
American business culture what can we
learn from that failure what was the
last one lean manufacturing was
basically it was very value focused was
rejected by American business culture
says William Petri yeah where we learned
from failures like that so the first one
around public organizations and how
they're structured so I know Tim knows
about this
so government digital services in the UK
was very interesting because they
basically questioned why is it that when
you need to search the web even though
you're in a government institution you
have to go to Google why don't we set up
our own you know our own website and
actually sorry the government asked this
and the first thing they did was say oh
but we're stupid we're government so
let's outsource it and they outsource it
to surco which is an organisation which
is like basically benefiting from lots
of outsourcing of governments worldwide
including by the way Obama's insurance
program was outsourced to circa just
crazy given it was an insurance policy
it wasn't anything else and and so and
it failed they charged government a huge
amount and produce a really crappy
website and so this group went from the
BBC which is a really interesting public
organization because it has had an
internal debate about public value which
again is a word that doesn't really
exist in economics we talk about social
values and aggregation of all these
individual value decisions but public
value doesn't exist and this group
inside the BBC who had actually been
focused around the BBC iPlayer moved
over to the Cabinet Office and set up
government digital services in order to
create this website using internal
expertise and the first thing they did
was say we need to reject the current
understanding of what citizens our
citizens have been sold to us as kind of
clients and customers but citizens are
fundamentally users and they use this
focus
on the citizen is user to design the
website and not just a user-friendly way
but also in a way that really increase
the participation and the ease through
which citizens were basically
interacting with the welfare state in
that process saved the government
billions I think it's something like 5
billion but without focusing on
efficiency so their their objective was
not efficiency it was really on creating
a better system for the user made it one
of the sexiest places to work so tech
city or silicon roundabout was having a
hard time to hire some of the you know
best computer engineers they all it was
an honor to work in GDS and they won a
big international design award and it's
just a very interesting example to me
because it required again upsetting and
debunking some of the underlying
assumptions that had been operating
before the BBC also as I mentioned is
very interesting because it has always
rejected the static notion of what
public and private are so the BBC's
always told just fix a market failure
and if they did that they would have
best just done documentaries about
giraffes in Africa and high-quality news
instead they also dared to go into you
know to really redefine the market again
co-create Co shape not just fix and
enter places areas like soap operas and
talk shows but really kind of redefining
those rethinking what it is to make a
soap opera so not Dallas and dynasty but
EastEnders so a soap opera about the
working class which then crowded in
other private actors into that space and
so really being dynamic and ambitious is
fundamental and this is why by the way
that data that I showed before with the
NIH is also problematic so the National
Institutes of Health yes their public
and spent huge amounts over 30 billion
in pharmaceutical research but why just
drugs they haven't been ambitious enough
to really redefine what the market is so
much less is spent on diagnostic
surgical treatments and hardly anything
a lifestyle lifestyle changes need
serious research shouldn't just be kind
of voodoo in thinking that you can just
wear sandals and eat yogurt and do yoga
on the beach you know we need proper all
things we all do
and so and and and I think that's that
the point that was making earlier you
know really be in being ambitious and
making these areas also contested
bringing different voices to the table
of how to redefine the market
I mean corporate corporate value you
know there's no one number but what's
interesting is you know it's not just
about well first of all I mean just
let's just put out some really obvious
things I mean paying the living wage or
you know that's it's it's a no-brainer
reinvesting profits in the workforce so
that skills themselves remain a dynamic
outcome of the investment process itself
but I think this you know just looking
at it in terms of corporate organization
without looking at it in terms of how
that organization is interacting with
the other actors I think there's a real
opportunity to create metrics which are
both internal in terms of like the
examples I just gave but there'd be many
others but also in terms of the
relationships and that does require this
concept of stakeholder value to become a
way of thinking of the dynamics of the
economy itself and actually having
metrics for that there's unfortunately a
tendency now in many countries which
have been disillusioned with what's
happening in business to say oh let's
just nationalize business as opposed to
rethinking the so this this probably
there was a question here she
nationalized Facebook oh well but sorry
just to finish this point you know the
real issue is what are the conditions
attached with business what are the
obligations between business and you
know for example in the UK Branson
entered the rail sector with no
conditions attached and in fact hasn't
been making the kind of investments he
should be making that example he gave
with Bell Labs before was a condition
attached the conditions that should be
attached and I think we need metrics
just as much for that and that would
require metrics that would help us
define whether the kinds of partnerships
you know everyone talks about
public-private partnerships or actually
symbiotic a mutualistic or parasitic and
any biologists would tell you that you
need to do that if you talk about an
ecosystem what kind of ecosystem
Facebook actually I know Tim's thinking
quite a bit about this the question is
not the size it's really can we actually
look at the degree to which and coming
back to a productive and unproductive
some of the activities really are purely
kind of rent extraction and I think that
is a really important question because
just because you break up a company
you're not necessarily breaking up the
process through which it's being
problematic and I think much more
attention needs to be given to that I
don't know if you've heard about this in
fact you should invite her to give a
talk here Shoshanna Zhu buffs book
surveillance capitalism you know looking
at those issues are are very important
in terms of thinking what to do with
Facebook who are the other economists
paying attention to you and that you pay
attention to the other yeah well I mean
I you know we obviously as a community
talk to each other I think there's
sometimes different understandings of
you know as I mentioned rent so someone
like Stiglitz I you know he won the
Nobel Prize for his model of asymmetric
information and so you know I would have
sort of a different opinion to him and
we talk I don't judge us Nicholas I
talked to people like Jeff Sachs and
Krugman who are all more in the
mainstream but our would see themselves
as progresses but what's interesting is
there's a huge debate and variety even
within progressive economists it's not
as if you just have the mainstream and
then the heterodox within the heterodox
there's a huge variety and I think that
itself the really sad thing is that we
no longer teach history of economic
thought mmm-hmm it's not only economic
history we don't teach but history of
economic thought and so the appreciation
of how many of these questions aren't
just about policy but as I've been
saying these different assumptions that
underlie for example different theories
of value when we only teach one theory
of value and don't even call it value we
call it econ 101 that has actually hurt
even the debate between the heterodox
economists and unfortunately one thing
that I've really often critiqued
explicitly is that this idea that you
know austerity is bad invest in
infrastructure you know it's like my god
really
you know we can't just be thinking it's
about pouring more money into the system
without having a really refined
understanding of you know what kind of
infrastructure and again how can we
really have that kind of directional
push to transforming a system which is
not just building roads and bridges but
having you know this market shaping and
I think many economists that I speak to
in the mainstream one of the things I
differ from them the most is this idea
of market failure theory well it's very
long a point you're making the history
of economics among other things your
slide on how it's changed from century
to century looking at the history sort
of gives you permission to think about
how is Economics going to change and
policy going to change now at the level
that it has changed at various times in
history
if you don't look at history then you
assume the present is the world and and
the long now it gives you this
understanding that it has changed and
how it changed and why it changed and
that there was urgency or whatever it
may be that all then becomes part of the
narrative of social license to change
again yeah disciplinarity is really
important economists not only don't read
economic history and history of economic
thought they don't really read anything
else they don't read philosophy they
don't read so the top economists
including you know Keynes or someone who
I really admire who was Karl Polanyi
they you know they were historians and
philosophers and economists sort of at
the same time and there's a real I think
need for that to come back in economics
which again shouldn't though be confused
with just take out the maths
yeah I mean this shouldn't be about
qualitative versus quantitative we can
still have serious quantitative methods
and use different types of methods but
what happened in economics is that
instead of saying oh look at that
interesting problem hmm which kind of
you know which tool am I going to throw
at it what they actually said is this is
what we want to prove you kind of Pareto
optimal kinds of outcomes and showed
that markets are the best possible way
to or capitalist market systems and how
they define them or the best possible
way to organize a system and the best
tools the tools that we need
in order to prove that point are coming
again from Newtonian physics so is a
deeply unscientific method we should
have lots of different tools including
by the way Newtonian physics but also in
terms of our statistical methods there's
lots of different you know possibilities
there there's case studies deep case
studies that we can be using alongside
you know quantitative techniques and
unfortunately when economics is driven
so much by ideology we end up kind of
choosing which tool is going to help me
prove the point I want to make and that
that kind of problematic lack of
scientific method is something that
needs to be challenged bring it on Thank
You Mariana this is great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]